we know that angles can be measured in
two ways degrees and radians let's
understand degrees first angles are
simply a union of two rays let this be
one ray there are two special kinds of
angles which are used very often one
angle looks like this and it's called a
right angle it measures ninety degrees
this small circle after the number is
used to denote degrees and do not
confuse this degrees with the degrees we
use to measure temperature they are two
different things and the second special
angle is the angle which forms a
straight line and is called a straight
angle and the measure of this angle is
180 degrees and when this arm will
rotate and overlap the initial arm it is
called one full rotation which equals
180 plus 180 360 degrees this brings us
to the question why 360 degrees why not
one thousand degrees because one
thousand sounds very convenient to me
why can't one full rotation be one
thousand degrees well think about it I
will probably be making another video to
explain this how do we measure or draw
angles in our notebook we use something
called a protractor and it looks
something like this the numbers you see
on the protractor are degrees first
let's see how we can measure angles
using a protractor let's say we want to
measure this angle to measure an angle
there are only two things we need to do
we need to keep this arm of the angle at
the zero angle position and the vertex
of the angle at the center of the
protractor normally we take the
protractor to the angle but in this
video I will be taking the angle to the
protractor like this now we are in a
position to measure the angle this arm
will be like our initial arm which is
the zero angle and this arm will be the
terminal arm which tells us the angle
measure we can see that it measures
slightly more than 50 degrees somewhere
close to 53 degrees that's how simple it
is to measure an angle with a protractor
but wait look at it very closely it has
two sets of angles marked the inner
semicircle goes from 0 to 180 this way
and the outer semicircle goes from 0 to
180 degrees this way but this time we
used the inner circle to measure the
angle Y think about it it's a bit
intuitive of course this angle is not
130 degrees this angle is acute and
hence we chose the inner semicircle and
got the measure somewhere close to 53
degrees but then why do we need the
other set of angles let's draw another
angle like this how do we measure this
angle we use the same procedure we keep
the vertex of the angle on the center of
the protractor and this arm on the zero
angle so we place it like this look at
the angle it's a cute it's not anywhere
close to 130 degrees so this time we use
the outer semicircle the zero angle
starts here and we get the measure as 53
degrees if we had just one set of angles
it would have been very difficult to
measure this angle we would have had to
tilt the protractor a bit so yes we are
given these two sets of angles primarily
for convenience